hackers found this man's location in a
couple of minutes after his 2 days trip
to La he flew back to Dallas and the
moment they landed he received a message
wow welcome back to Dallas I can't
believe you were gone for so long we
should totally hang out this just
freaked me up how do people know that I
was leaving we'll show you how
everything revolves around an IP logger
and a URL shortener you click this link
and then you go to IP logger code you
put in any real website you click that
button and it generates a short code
like this
now the hacker can send it to him and
when he goes into something like an
incognito window and he simply pastes
that address it takes him to his own
website and that's when the hackers can
check all this information his IP
address and even the country the city
and in fact if we click on map it even
Maps out his exact location scary how
simple it
is